il s'est écoulé six ans depuis cette
nuit de terreur comme paris n'en avait
jamais connu 130 morts des centaines et
des centaines de blessés ou des accusés
après neuf longs mois de témoignages et
de plaidoirie dix neuf des vingt accusés
ont été reconnus coupables de tous les
chefs d'accusation par la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris salle abdeslam le seul
membres encore en vie des commandos a
été condamné à la perpétuité
incompressible
une peine qui le prive de toute
possibilité de libération conditionnelle
avant 30 ans il avait été le dernier des
accusés à s'exprimer lundi dernier il a
voulu expliquer son évolution depuis
l'ouverture du procès à l'époque il
s'était empressé de se dire combattants
de l'état islamique puis il a changé son
ton et ses propos je ne suis pas un
assassin je ne suis pas un tueur avait
il dit lundi et si vous me condamnez
pour assassinat vous commettrez une
injustice
au contraire dit cette avocate
représentant des victimes sa lourde
peine est tout à l'honneur de la cour
c'était très important dans cette
gangrène terroristes il fallait dire le
droit et surtout je voudrais insister la
cour a eu beaucoup de courage je veux
saluer ce courage
la cour n'a pas cru l'accusé quand il a
déclaré avoir renoncé à se faire
exploser
hélas plutôt considéré que son gilet
explosif était défectueux remettant
sérieusement en cause les déclarations
de salles abdeslam sur son renoncement
par humanité avait-il dit je suis de
gauche fort heureusement cet avocat qui
représente aussi des parties civiles la
perpétuité incompressible c'est très
rare dans notre droit français et c'est
un message qui s'adresse à tous les pays
du monde là où les islamistes peuvent
préparer
les attentats
tolérance zéro les peines prononcées par
la cour vont de 1 à 30 ans de prison
pour cette avocate de la défense il
s'agit de peines lourdes dans les
petites quêtes du terrorisme pose
problème il ya des raccourcis qui sont
fait des raccourcis intellectuels et que
je trouve assez dangereux et liberticide
par conséquent et j'aurais aimé qu'on
applique avec plus de
justesse son client ayant déjà servi une
partie de sa peine durant la durée du
procès il devrait être libre dans
quelques jours mais il pourrait malgré
tout faire appel du verdict pour les
milliers de parties civiles le verdict
annonce la fin d'un long processus
souvent douloureux parfois réparateur
mais c'est aussi le début de quelque
chose une vie qu'il faut maintenant
inventer
si la presse ou les cils part de vous
même
et
seddik c'est paradoxalement difficile de
de quitter cet endroit
parce que
ça a été
un endroit aussi reconstruit on a
redémarré des choses près de 400
survivants et membres des familles des
victimes ont été entendus à la barre ils
ont offert à la cour ici souvent
glaçante de cette terrible nuit thierry
maillet lui assistera à un concert
demain soir il ne saurait en être
autrement je suis ni deux fois
le 13 novembre c'était ma deuxième
naissance pour que là je vais je vais
vivre
vivre mais sans jamais oublier les morts
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris